one california house seat flipping from
blue to red republican michelle steele
defeating her democratic challenger the
incumbent
in a very close race that cook political
report
labeled lean democrat so steele's win
adding to the record number of
republican when elected wins
elected to congress this year look at
that congresswoman elect michelle steele
joins us now good morning to you
congressman
congresswoman elect how are you
i'm doing great thank you very much for
inviting me i'm sure you are
you're welcome congratulations on
flipping the seat how did you do it
you know what i just stick to the issues
because
you know i already have a proven record
lower taxes
and less regulations since you know
kobe 19 we closed down almost like eight
months most of
you know businesses being closed down so
i stick to the issues
and another thing is that you know there
are a lot of people want to
defund the police or dismantling instead
that you know what i actually declared
orange county law enforcement
appreciation date
and you know what we have to support
police
and all these law enforcement officers
because 99
of these people are good people we keep
training
and we reform but you know what we
cannot dismantle or we cannot defund
so i just stick to the issues and i
think that's the reason that i won
i know that you and marilyn strickland
are the first two korean-american women
that have been elected to congress she
is a democrat and she won
in seattle tell me your story what made
you want to serve
you know what actually uh first
generation and i
was born in korea raised in japan so i
speak korean as my first and japanese my
second language
and english is my third never thought my
mom actually was harassed by one of the
tax agencies they called
state board of equalization that's the
reason that i decided to run for state
board of equalization and that's the way
i
started this is my fifth election i want
all
five you know what i stand for american
dream
what do you make of so many women and
minorities being elected this year
you know what republican party is
growing i mean you know
me with my accent i still want
and people actually when we stick to the
issues and we just try to
work with residents and work for
residents i think
we're gonna keep winning yeah your
accent is part of your story you're a
beautiful person you speak three
languages and don't let anyone tell you
differently
congratulations go out there and fight
in washington i will thank you very much
for inviting me
you're welcome